I have always looked at what we call the  equity premium in financial markets that  is the rate of return over the sovereign  debt yield that financial markets are  more exactly equity markets require in  order to invest that yield got to an  extraordinarily high in fact the 50-year  high when the crash occurred and that  said that we were way out of line with  where we ordinarily would be and it was  just a matter of time before the equity  premium declined it's now come back to  what I would see is closer to normal  after being exceptionally high and that  means that no we are not yet in this in  a stressful position but then you  recover the stock market has recovered  so sharply for so long you have to  assume somewhere along the line we're  going to get a significant correction  where that is I do not know